[Music]
do you want to start playing the Ghost
Recon wildlands open beta as soon as it
goes live well if you're on the west
coast like me then you're gonna have to
wake up pretty early to do that I'm Matt
this is a game spot news update and make
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
videos from ghost recon open beta
Ubisoft confirmed VG 24-7 that the
wildlands open beta starts at three a.m.
pacific on februari 23rd that six a.m.
eastern in 11 a.m. greenwich mean time
you can preload it on ps4 xbox one and
pc right now but make sure you have
twenty four gigabytes of space available
on your system as that's what it's going
to take to play it the open beta
contains everything from the closed beta
as well as a new province called Monte
yok it's populated by strongholds that
house the drug cartels strongest
soldiers so you'll probably need some
guns to take them out but before you
start shooting up drug dealers make sure
to check out our video on the five
things you need to know before playing
The Ghost Recon wildlands open beta